-Thank you for being here, pal.
-My absolute pleasure.
I miss you. I love you deeply.
-I do. I miss you.
I'm always happy to see you.
We had a good
little exchange backstage.
I think this could be
a new thing.
-We did.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I really -- I loved it.
I love it
because it was so genuine.
It was real. It was real.
-Yeah, and surveys say
that it is 73% less bacteria.
-That's exactly correct. Yeah.
-What did you call it?
A pinkie pound.
-A pinkie point?
Oh, pinkie pound.
A pinkie pound, yeah.
-A pinkie pound.
-Yeah, pinkie pound right there.
That's our thing.
I love it, yeah.
I mean --
-It's big on TikTok.
-That's true.
On TikTok, every kid is
doing pinkie pound.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Every time you're on the show,
we talk about music,
and I love to talk to you
about music,
because you're a great musician.
I know you love music.
How long have you been in your
band, 30 Seconds --
-Since -- I mean, forever.
My brother
and I started as kids.
And we actually signed
a record deal in 1998.
And we've been doing it --
-'98.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A long time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, thank you.
And, you know,
our last concert, in 2018,
was at Madison Square Garden
here in New York.
-Was that right?
-Yeah.
And -- Of course.
But New York --
the best audiences in the world.
-No, it's unbelievable.
Yeah, and let's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, isn't that great?
I agree, but do you --
-My point was, it's just amazing
to do it this long,
and our last show was arguably
one of our best shows,
and it was at, you know, the
most iconic venue in the world.
-MSG. Do you ever -- Do you
pinch yourself when you play?
-Often.
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, like you don't.
-No, yeah --
-Like you don't.
-Someone's like,
"I'd pinch you, Jared."
No, I mean, like when
you think of your upbringing.
And you're a kid.
You didn't have much.
You didn't have
any musical instruments.
-Yeah.
-You borrowed a guitar, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, we were pretty --
You know, my mom --
We were born in Louisiana.
-Yeah.
-We didn't have a lot.
My mom put herself through
college, went back to school.
She had dropped out of high
school and went back to school
and then went to nursing school
and, you know,
wanted to make a better life
for herself and her kids.
And she taught us a lot,
you know?
I owe her a lot.
-Yeah.
-She really taught us that
the impossible is possible
if you're willing
to do the hard work.
-Yeah. And you do --
-I mean, you're going to
make me cry up here.
-Yeah, that's not my --
You do the hard work.
That's good.
-Yeah.
-You do do the hard work.
I mean, from every role
that you've been on,
you've been nice enough
to come on our show.
You've either lost 40 pounds.
You gained 60 pounds.
Like, you do this stuff,
extreme stuff.
You put the work in,
and it pays off.
I mean, here you are.
You're selling out
Madison Square Garden,
for God's sakes.
-Yeah, it's incredible.
And, you know, the older I get,
I just have an
enormous sense of gratitude
to do what I do.
And, you know,
the transformative process,
for me,
is really fascinating.
I love immersive acting.
I love to see if I can
really create a new life
and share it with people.
And that's what I did in
"House of Gucci"
with the one-and-only
Paolo Gucci.
-Yeah.
-Paolo Gucci.
I mean, you're unrecognizable
in this film.
But, also, the way you --
Your accent is unbelievable,
as well.
It's -- Well, here's the thing.
When I see you,
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
I just -- I talk to you.
We have fun. We laugh.
And then I see you
in front of --
What was the one concert?
I think it was like 100,000
people or something crazy.
-Yeah, it's -- You know,
we spent a lot of time
on the road touring.
So, as you guys know,
our life is really
about being on the road.
Every song that we write --
We actually --
In COVID, I wrote over --
I think it's
about 264 songs now.
It's amazing what a little --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much, yeah.
You haven't heard them yet,
so hold the applause.
-Yeah. 263 are eh,
but one is whoo!
-It's amazing what a little --
A little banana bread
really stokes the creativity.
Like, I shut down
a banana bread.
-A little banana bread.
-A little "Tiger King."
Bam!
-It goes a long way.
-Exactly. It goes a long way.
-But I'm actually having
a hard time
coming up with an album title.
And I thought, you're a such --
He's so great with music.
I mean, the voice of
an angel you have.
Really do.
-Thank you so much.
-You do.
-I mean, yeah.
-But I thought maybe you could
help me come up --
-Yes. Yes.
-And if you have a good one,
I'm going to take it,
just so you know.
-You are?
-Yes. Absolutely.
-Alright, so, this is
all these songs you wrote.
All 264.
-Yeah, it was a dark --
It's a tough time.
I thought maybe one could be,
you know, something edgy
like [bleep] you,
you [bleep] [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
It's a little angry, I know.
-Yeah. I already had that.
-Or maybe
"The Incredible True Adventures
of a Labradoodle Named..."
-Uh, Tortney.
-Tortney!
-How about the --
-Tortney.
-Exiting a cave.
-Exiting a cave?
-The exit -- Yeah.
Oh, how about --
-Yeah.
-Tomago.
-How about --
how about "Egg Life"?
-We could do -- We could name
it after someone --
-You guys are all in
an egg, like that.
-Yeah, we're in egg heads.
-Yeah, you got egg heads.
-It's like a Bowie thing.
-Yeah, you don't --
You're not quite --
It's called
"Not Ready to Hatch."
-We could name it after someone
who has done something,
you know, remarkable.
Like, we'd name it after a
real person, like Elon Musk
or maybe Kanye.
He's not using his name anymore.
-No, yeah.
He got rid of his name.
Yeah, legally,
we're allowed to get --
"Kanye" is the name of the next
30 Seconds to Mars album.
-Thank you very much.
-That's it right there.
"Kanye."
-Thank you.
-He's not using it.
-Thank you!
-You got it.
-You should do that.
-I appreciate it.
-Can I just ask you about
a couple photos?
Because I love
showing pictures of you,
because I live vicariously
through you in these photos.
I knew you're very into
rock-climbing.
-Yes. Yes.
-Or do you just call it
climbing?
Is there a name for it?
-We call it rock-climbing.
-Yeah.
-Wow. Here's a picture.
This is real.
I didn't --
-Yeah.
-Yeah. No filter here.
-That's Jared Leto. Yeah.
And are you on a cord?
Or what's happening? No.
-We call it a rope.
-You were on a rope.
But this is actually more --
It kind of has
a bouldering vibe to it.
Bouldering is when
you don't use a rope,
but you climb,
you know, boulders.
-Yeah, that's bouldering.
-Yeah, I love it.
It's a passion of mine.
And, yeah,
that was recently in Sardinia.
I was actually with
my good friend,
Alex Honnold, from "Free Solo."
-Oh, "Free Solo." Of course.
That guy's a legend.
-He's right down here.
-I mean, look at that.
That's insane.
Do you get frightened
or did you get --
-No, no, no, no.
I mean, you could wear
a diaper, I guess,
if you're worried
about it, but --
-I would.
-But I'm pretty used to it now
and I absolutely love it.
You seem like
you would be great at it,
because I've always gotten the
sense that you're very limber.
-Oh.
Do you get that sense?
-Do you not get that sense?
-You get that sense from me?
-I thought that
you were very flexible.
-Well, no, I'm just
all upper-body strength.
-Oh, you are?
-My legs are very weak.
-Oh, yeah. Well, me too.
-Yeah.
-I mean, here, do you want --
Just lift me.
-No, no, no, no.
I'd probably drop you.
I'm, you know --
-I just -- That's the only way
I can kind of
get out of chairs now.
I've spent all
my time upper body
that I have forgotten
about my legs.
And I could stand right here,
but just very weak.
-That's pretty good.
Pretty good. Pretty good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I would love to
take you sometime,
if you'd like to go with
me, Alex Honnold.
-I would love to go.
Would I bother you?
I wouldn't want to bother you
and ruin the --
-You probably would.
-I would, yeah.
I don't want to ruin
the experience for you.
Like, you're up here because
you don't want to see me.
-No, no, no, no.
-You're going to the top of
a place where there's no humans.
You're like, "I'm good, man.
I want to get up here."
So you don't want to be
with Jimmy Fallon
going like,
"Hey, man, can you show me --"
-You could do part of a show
hanging from the side of
the cliff in Yosemite.
El Captain.
Wouldn't that be amazing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can we --
-Alex could probably
put you on his shoulders
and carry you up there.
-Alex -- I would do that.
Yeah, if you want.
I weigh like,
well, you know, about 120.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 120 pounds,
something like that.
Yeah, so I can just
hop on his back.
What do you carry
in your backpack?
Carabiners?
-Excuse me?
-Carabiners.
-Oh, I thought you said wieners.
-A can of wieners.
-I was like, "Actually..."
No.
-A can of wieners? Yeah.
Yeah, a can of wiener.
Vienna sausage is --
-Carabiner, can of wieners --
that's something.
-Something there.
-We should go on "Shark Tank."
-Album title!
-Oh, album title!
-Hey!
-"Can of Wieners"!
Jared, I want to
talk to you about --
I want to talk to you about
"House of Gucci," okay?
More with Jared Leto
when we come back.
Come on back, everybody.